Allora te lo dico già le facciamo rosze
rosso natale No vabbè ma hai solo questi
di Rossi Sì A Natale andiamo a Cortina
poi invece a capodanno andiamo Al callo
parto il 31 A proposito mi chiedevo Ma
se io oggi ho fatto il rosso Natale per
Natale no se vengo il 31 mattina prima
di andare all'aeroporto riesco a fare il
rosso Borgogna per Capodanno per Io
vorrei fare due unghie effetto tartan
Dai amo effetto scozzese amo così in una
vorrei quelle leccalecca natalizio
capito quale tipo così Capito no cioè
boh la sfumatura di rosso che voglio io
non c'è Sì le volevo rosse Natale ma non
quel rosso capito un rosso un
po' più fine non lo trovo se lo trovavo
te lo dicevo Eh come sei chiusa ma
capodanno non è mica il 31 è il 31 sera
tu il 31 dovresti lavorare una giornata
lavorativa a tutti gli effetti per
quelli che lavorano o no signora o no Io
vorrei anche Babbo Natale ma non solo la
faccia Cioè proprio faccia corpo sacco
sulle spalle e anche una renna Se riesci
se riesci a farli stare tutti e due un
un'unghia meglio se mi fai slittare la
renna l'altra unghia va bene uguale
consiglio di prenderne un po' di più di
smalti cioè ogni volta non so mai che
colore fare a momento è più fornita mia
cugina si lamentano che non c'è lavoro e
poi non vogliono lavorare eh no ma non
si fa così in un'unghia Voglio la faccia
di Kevin di mammma perso l'aereo dai
quella in cui fa così Ah questa